[...]
Consider two dilemmas.
You are a university
student, and you discover
that your roommate, who is also your
best friend, has cheated on an exam.
You wonder whether to report
her to university authorities.
Or suppose you are an
excellent swimmer and you're
a member of your country's
Olympic swimming team.
Shortly before the
swimming event you discover
that a teammate has been taking
illegal performance-enhancing drugs.
You wonder whether to report
him to the authorities.
Thinking about these
dilemmas raises a question
about loyalty and truth-telling.
Do you think it is sometimes
right to lie or to hide the truth
to protect a friend, a teammate, or a
compatriot who's done something wrong?